hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to as you
all know I am a perfect God among men
who makes absolutely no mistakes
whatsoever why because I have a crack
team of researchers and scientists to
make sure that every single solitary
thing I put in my video is absolutely
perfect and not that I need them being
the Messiah that I am but even I like to
be sure that everything is absolutely
perfect
what was that holy right there oh my
most obnoxious fan do she make nitpick
I've watched every single one of your
videos 37 times and have a shitload a
mistake that you should be hanged for
hey fine okay
okay you probably guessed I don't have a
team of researchers and scientists to
check over everything I do it's all just
me or the occasional on hooker so every
once in a while I make one or two little
mistakes piggy 5670 to be exact
all right so to make up for all my
little fault look at you say we take a
look back at all the times I mess
something up it's nostalgia critic yet
so sit back and enjoy this laundry list
of my greatest failures this is the top
11 nostalgia critic mock-ups it's fuckin
team fuckup
and Jordan
everything
again
number one
the actors from Power Rangers didn't
leave because of their race although I
sort of knew this to be true and was
really making more of a joke about it I
said to my Power Rangers review the to
the actors left because the black boy
was in the black suit and the aging girl
was in a yellow suit which wasn't very
piecey the actual leaving of the actors
was not for that reason
in fact the Red Ranger disappeared at
this time as well why did they leave I'm
not really sure some say it was a money
issue others say it was because they
weren't popular enough I personally
don't know and to be honest I don't
really know why you need an excuse to
leave the show but the one that I gave
wasn't it however I still think it was a
little more than a coincidence that the
black he was going to black soon the
Asian kid was put the yellow suit it's
like giving a Mexican Power Ranger
sombrero eh it just doesn't seem right
so again apologies if anybody got the
wrong idea you should be waterboarded
and cow urine shut up shut up
number two
a banshees in the scariest nostalgic
moment you freaking idiot again thanks
for the comment not to be fair this was
the very first half on let him Liz diver
did so it only makes sense that wouldn't
be necessarily fast
I put the Banshee from Darby O'Gill and
the little people as number one because
it really did scare the shit out of me
it's still kind of duds
I just went myself right now it's that
scary but the more I look at the more I
realize it is a pretty cheap effect if
you didn't see the movie like a lot of
people did you didn't have any time to
let the atmosphere build up which i
think is a big part of it it probably
would have been wiser to put Willy
Wonka's diamond tunnel at number one and
then maybe throw the we loose in from
Return to Oz in the other spot but I
don't care I still find this bitch scary
even if no one else does
still I should've thought more about it
and what would be universally scary as
opposed to what just scared me
if I just went by what scares me I have
a Pauly Shore movies probably be on the
list not one of my better picks but just
keep in mind that was quite literally my
first pick stop bad y'all stop bad
number nine
why were you wearing a laying there in
the Superman countdown this is one of my
more embarrassing fuck-ups actually film
this review right after I filmed another
certain sketch a certain sketch that
will never be named a melvin melvin
brother doctor joker yeah Mel's another
of the joke what a different song so
yeah I thought I got all the makeup off
from that sketch but obviously a dozen
email saying I look like a goth drag
show proves me wrong so I had to do the
whole review looking like a pussy end of
story
I mean it's not like I walk around
wearing all the women's apparel all the
time
Lucy where did you get that from my
deepest hate of you I also have a
picture of you kissing divine and doing
the tank air with Hitler look he's doing
the can-can with Hitler oh I'm funny
those were all juice juice on posters
yeah it's pretty bad when it tribute to
someone's work doesn't have a good chunk
of their work for example this Star Wars
poster wasn't his and neither was this
one for Follow That Bird this and a
couple others were actually done by
Steven short a was also a wonderful
artist working in that same source
Troodon style in fact I found out that
he actually is often mistaken for Drew
Struzan so you can understand the mess
up it's good work though if you don't
know his stuff definitely check out his
website it really kicks ass with me
saying it was Drew Struzan however it
was just another one of my fuck-ups but
to be fair Drew Struzan himself sent me
an email on dead series about this and
said that most people that do interviews
or stories about him always get the
wrong posters he also said if anything I
was one of the closest he's ever seen to
getting them all right so
tourism
the secret passageway in babies kids
isn't impossible now this one I will
always defend because I don't think I
was wrong on this if you don't remember
the bed here's how it went well
apparently going to the left side of the
bookcase drops you off in one room and
going to the right side of the bookies
dropped you off in another that's just
impossible I mean think about it if a
bookcase opens up it spins around in a
circle so that means that there can only
be one room because if there's a wall
separating the two rooms the bookcase
would it open now a lot of people have
told me that it can open up and lead to
two different rooms at the wall dividing
the two room stops at just what bookcase
stops turning true but here's my
argument if the wall only goes that far
then technically you can just turn the
book keys back a bit and easily squeeze
into the other room meaning you're not
just limited to where the bookcase leads
you the only way you couldn't get
through this room is if you were the
size of a hippo or something and you're
not you're the size of a fucking little
kid so my opinion this still makes no
sense I fuck up no you look at that but
to the credit of those who complained
about this I guess I could say that
maybe I could have explained it a little
better and that technically can count as
a fuck of them that's a horrible game
anyway so who gives a shit hey dude I
can't trust an internet celebrity who
watches cartoons and shout obscenities
that who can I trust people with some
expertise Oh
number six there wasn't for gifted
barbed wire not a bulldozer yes this is
one of my more obvious mistakes you
don't have to be a construction worker
to know the difference between a goddamn
bulldozer in a forklift for some reason
I in fact did called forklift a
bulldozer I don't know what I was
thinking and so obviously a forklift how
could I get that wrong plus as many
people pointed out it forced me to leave
out probably one of the most obvious
jokes I ever could have put in a review
looking to be so bad if I just said it
once except for the fact I said it over
and over again logos of oldest bulldozer
driver so obviously I couldn't just save
us a slip of a tongue my tongue would be
more slippery than banana peels skating
on greasy black ice that was forced
Chuck you shut up oh nice number father
there wasn't a carny in Last Action Hero
now some of you might not even know what
I'm talking about here first of all he
was in Last Action Hero
wasn't he he's the guy that dies right
before he gets blown up a little
redundant but whatever well that's not
what I said when I first did the review
somehow I got it mixed up and thought
that the actor who played the theater
custodian was our carny and that this
other guy was someone else
when in fact the actor's real name was
Robert rouse key and of course this is
the guy our car he played now I actually
caught this mistake fairly early on and
actually switched the names around
before I sent it out to be posted but
the switchings of the name was pretty
obvious Danny is friends with the
projection is that a movie theatre
played by Robert Pross key press key
offers him an advance screening Danny
heads to the movie theater where Kraske
is waiting the kid has had an amazing
adventure he reunites with the press key
character well luckily I'll never do
something like that again I mean I've
never got mistake Robert Prowse key for
someone like Art Carney ever again but
wait a minute I was the first person to
see their review because I waited till
3:00 a.m. to watch it and I heard you
say are Carney suck it actually he's
right because for a whole entire day the
wrong version was out so thousands of
people constantly heard me call the
wrong guy are Carney over and over and
over but in all honesty this wasn't my
fault
I sent the corrected version in but the
person who was posting videos at the
time accidentally posted the wrong one
and the person who posted that review
was Mike Ellis now Mike Ellis has done a
lot for the site he's a lot behind the
scenes stuff and technical stuff but
nevertheless he made a mistake so you
have anything to say Mike I certainly do
I was new to putting videos up and you
can't blame you for making a mistake
every once in a while so for what it's
worth I do apologize there now you see
there's no problem too big that can't be
solved by a humble apology unfortunately
that punky wasn't good enough
now clean up your own blood okay well
water under the bridge a mistake that
didn't last long but certainly left a
long impression mrs. Dewey fished it big
moron yeah this is from my Godzilla
review I pointed out that luring
Godzilla with fish really didn't make
any sense because lizards don't eat fish
they eat bugs but I've heard that there
actually are some forms of lizards that
do in fact eat fish which of course
makes my statement wrong but really does
that excuse this horrible line that's a
lot of fish I still don't get it good
one
oh nothing too much don't we say about
this one
I said lizards don't eat fish they do so
let's move on idiot number three how
dare you make fun of me kill you ain't
nary bastard
yes I'll never hear the end of this one
this all started with the TMNT review
which I'd like to point out everybody
requested me to do and you got really
pissed off when I did it does my
audience just a multiple personality
disorder well anyway it got to the part
where splinter shows up and I simply
didn't think his voice matched it just
sounded way too shaky for me it wasn't
like the splinters I heard before well
this started an outrage from Mako fans I
didn't know who the guy was but I
quickly found out apparently he's an
incredibly beloved actor having been
nominated for an Oscar and doing
constant voiceover work in the hit show
avatar it also been held that the guy
died from Safa Gill cancer now made a
frigging cigarette joke in the review
each of your brothers Oh what did they
do this players voice it sounds like mr.
Miyagi if he smoked a million Marlboros
was
I eventually posted a video explaining
that I had no intention of insulting the
guy and even joked about in my sidekicks
review so I guess some good came out of
it but the damage was done and the
message was clear nobody fucks with Mako
you said it mom number two you're castin
spelling mistakes jackass yes if you
watch my videos you may notice a pattern
that there's a lot of spelling mistakes
it's not of like if you cross a dyslexic
with a complete idiot I do my best to
try to correct my many spelling errors
but no matter how hard I try to keep
getting through especially loved the one
at the end of a kid in King Arthur's
Court I smashed my head to make myself
forget about the horrible movie and then
misspell one of the words in the credits
a lot of people thought this was part of
the joke that I smashed my head so hard
that I got the spelling wrong uh yeah
that was it but my other spelling errors
prove me wrong there's even an incident
where I spell my own name nostalgia
critic wrong that is inexcusable
I suck I almost thought about making a
contest what response the first spelling
error and every future review will get a
fucking Xbox going downside is the one
being of Xbox in the world to give out
what can I say I'm not a bad writer I'm
just a piss-poor editor that was really
dope
the number one nostalgia critic fuckup
is how could you not put Optimus Prime
in the top 11 status nostalgic moments
yeah get them this is gonna haunt me
till the day I die when I did the top 11
saddest nostalgia moments I looked off
what many considered to be the saddest
one of all time the death of Optimus
Prime for the Transformers movie oh good
you you ignorant ass well it's just that
he died for your sin well I kind of
you're going to have a willing hey let
me explain you see I never actually sold
a transformer movie in theaters I didn't
even know there was one to tell I was a
freshman in high school by that time I
wasn't really into transform as much
anymore but a friend of mine forced me
to watch it anyway when Optimus Prime
died I thought it was more weird than it
was tragic in fact the whole film is a
bloodbath or boil math whatever you want
to call it I mean everyone seems to die
it's like it was the theme of the movie
or something live life of them fucking
die the end buy your products so I guess
I never really left an impression as
much as just left me confused however it
definitely left an impression with other
fans and they were certain to let me
know about it I feel so bad for leaving
it out that my next review I turn
Optimus Prime into Jesus Christ
now give me credit that was nice of me
remember I died for your suit
a people still to this day can't believe
I made such a huge mistake there were
protests in the streets nations went to
war and toured the world apart clearly
there was only one possible thing I
could do to give the situation the
dignity that it deserves I hired one of
the greatest generals to read a note of
apology that I personally wrote no I
pretty admit that my method was wrong
but I hope you can understand my motive
and will accept this explanation and
this apology just miss dad what I know
that looks like a clip from Patton but
it wasn't optimus dear optimus can you
ever forgive me I die for your shoes and
clearly I will only die for mine so that
about does it made a lot of mistakes in
the past and I'm sure to make a lot more
in the future
and as always if I ever make a mistake
don't ever be afraid to bring it up it's
the only way over just don't be a great
a asshole like do she make nitpick here
you forgot to mention that the guy who's
saying how the great still Christmas did
sing in the haunted mansion dr. Walter
well that too would be physically
impossible how could you find me if you
don't even know why
you clean up your own blood may
distilled run
okay get on a yahoo Bay that RV place
out out
fuck I really hurt myself god dammit